you guys see the latest uh crazy crime
video out of New York The Daily Mail
Stark naked man goes nuts at you and
square subway station and NYC as MTA
officials struggle to get him to calm
down before he runs into packed subway
cars I'm not going to show the video
yikes but this is just like the latest
in a series of videos there's like a
video of a lady getting pushed under the
subway tracks there's videos of like
people being shot and mugged it's just
like the amount of content coming out of
New York or or video footage of all of
these crimes in the escalation it's
Bonkers yeah it's like it's like living
in World Star Hip-Hop in real life
instead of just seeing it online you
have to deal with it every single day
there's no accountability anymore yeah
there's no there's no fear missing well
it used to feel like if you step out of
line the cops are going to grab you or
someone's going to shoot you now it's
like what where's the out of line what
where's the response where's the
protection what's the what's the point
of government why would you want to be a
cop at these cities why the entire
system of the city is designed to
backstab you so here's a great story
from Capitol Hill Washington DC we have
a cop I won't name him he's our neighbor
all right so he's down the street at the
end of the block uh nice little house
little American flag outside good cop
great cop during the BLM uh riots uh he
broke his leg chasing after some some
some perp and he breaks his leg jumps a
fence breaks his leg and so he's had a
lot of time on the couch like chat with
us about what the police force is like
in DC and through that time they could
not recruit to like fill the chairs
inside of their Academy like even
halfway you couldn't get any comps no
one wanted to be a cop no one still
wants to be a cop in Washington DC this
particular police officer is looking for
any opportunity to get out uh possible
now some of them want to migrate to
places like Florida where police
officers are respected and even paid by
Rhonda Santos you get a 5 000 bonus if
you're a cop that moves Florida and that
makes Florida a very safe place you ask
where do these communities exist I would
argue maybe the Midwest I was just back
in Iowa Iowa was very nice uh also in
Florida it is wild I like I go through
our neighborhood and I I my wife's gonna
kill me because we think this is a nice
best kept secret but like it's like
you're back in a Norman Rockwell
painting it's like the society functions
people walk their dogs kids do play in
the street and run around the
neighborhood by themselves it's it's
it's nuts and now the mayor of Tampa is
a former police officer and she's very
like uh she's her name's Jane Castro
she's very Law and Order you know no
riots here no no no antifa here right no
BLM uh uh uh looting here
but I I like I saw like I saw it break
down in in Washington DC with my cop
friend and you feel really bad about
them because suddenly you're like I'm
gonna be the last guy holding the bag
I'm gonna be the last I'm gonna be the
only guy on call like that cop in New
Orleans who is the only guy on call
and and he quit on the spot because he
like looks onto his recorder there
little machine he's like I'm the only
person responding to all of to all these
call-ins and he and you know he quit I
you know he he he did a Twitter thread
on it it's it's so terrible for these
police officers and these communities
that don't support them they're gonna
get what's coming to him which is what
you're talking about they gotta get rid
of this Mass crap too because people mob
going into stores with masks on is no
good they have cameras there for
security if you can't see who it is
that's a big danger it used to be
illegal to go into private organizations
with a mask on because it was a thread
well you should have privacy in my
opinion but all the same not in my
public a sad but not in my private
establishment you're not you're gonna
reveal who you are but if you before you
come in there you can make it you can
yeah that's up to them yeah on your
private property you can do whatever you
want but I still think you know the
government shouldn't be watching and
surveilling every single the private
company should be surveilling the people
that are coming in to buy stuff and they
and if they don't want mass then they
don't get to take your mask off before
you come into my store I want to see
your face I want to know who who I have
to go after if you're going to mess with
me
yeah the government mandated masks in a
lot of these circumstances so you
couldn't do that
so that's that needs to be repealed now
that we know that covet's done according
to Joe Biden well assuming Joe Biden is
correct pandemic
we all said that video is like I think
it was at a Philly as well where they
raid the Wawa they all storm in and
they're smashing everything and then the
chick jumps about the things that's
twerking and people are just like just
destroying everything for no reason yeah
I think we still got to be careful
calling for more police more
centralization of power more government
because look at what the government's
doing right now look what the cops are
doing right now criminals Psychopaths
robbers
they go to jail they get released from
jail political thought criminals stay in
jail heavily prosecuted heavily punished
and if you only enforce that system and
you give it more of your power and
authority and money I think the
situation is only going to be worse for
the average American uh so so I I think
we need do need to bring up George Soros
and how he financed a lot of the woke
District Attorneys all throughout the
United States that have implemented a
lot of these policies that punish People
based on their political ideology rather
than of course the severity of their
crime I think what we have seen is
deliberate I think it is order out of
chaos and I think the larger turnaround
here is people going to be like more
government more government more
government more police and then I think
that that could be used against a lot of
the people calling for it in my own
personal opinion from my own kind of
conspiracy mindset yeah I like arming
the population as opposed to creating
more police yeah personal responsibility
giving people more rights given giving
people the ability to to defend
themselves I think is a lot more
important to call for or rather than
more police more centralization more
government more money towards the state
which they're going to be abusing and
using in the worst case scenario against
the average American because if you look
at who the government is serving it's
not you they're not looking for your
best interest they're not here to really
protect and serve very few officers the
few should be commended should be
promoted should be respected but very
few officers actually live by that
notion of protecting and serving serving
a lot of them are here to give you
tickets and generate revenue for the
state and we just have to in my opinion
be a little bit careful when it comes to
more and more and more in in that
retrospect calling for for that one more
guns more personal responsibility more
freedom more Liberty and more Firearms
sure I think that would work out better
in my personal opinion and there would
be there would be a lot more uh there
would be a lot less harm reduction I saw
video game developers are now making the
gun when you what they call it flagging
if you point a gun at someone when
you're walking around with it they call
it flagging so you should never do that
no of course and in video games up until
now when you run your gun's always
pointing forward so you like and kids
are doing this whether or not they're
getting indoctrinated to think it's fine
to point a weapon maybe Alec Baldwin
forgot but you're supposed to the
developers are having the guns pointed
down now when you point at someone or
point it up and away when you're aiming
and then as soon as you move past them
you can set the gun back down that's
important man because we're brainwashing
kids with this stuff and we need to stop
that wasn't a gun responsibility that
was like Ian is just sitting here having
a conversation and then very very
quickly spun around a slap Alec Baldwin
in the face and go right back to a very
serious killed Helena Hutchins and I
wonder what's if her family's gonna lie
we need to make sure the kids are
playing the games and their guns are
ready Alec Baldwin by the way is a
murderer Baldwin said it's an example a
really bad example for people in the
film and television industry so Alec
Baldwin killed more people than every
single Rider on January
yeah yeah he should be charged and uh uh
whatever man I we talked a lot about the
Alec Baldwin stuff he pointed a gun at
somebody pulled the trigger he pulled
the hammer he pulled the trigger went
off and killed her just can't be sloppy
with guns it's easy to learn how to
shoot in the modern age I don't know I
just think it's ridiculous there's this
whole excuse where it's like but he was
on a movie
and it's like you can't commit a crime
but I was in a movie you know what I
mean like so the armorer uh you talk
about Jeremy boring daily wire released
a uh very cool uh movie called Terror on
the Prairie right and so we went there
and there was an armor I don't know any
armorers right Hollywood armor but there
was a dude there they shoot a lot of
guns in this movie Gino Carano uh was in
the movie anyway uh that this is the
first time I met an armorer like oh this
is cool Alec Baldwin immediately said oh
my God I figured out I get asked this
everywhere in the airport at the
supermarket everyone finds out what I do
and they ask me about Alec Baldwin and
I'm gonna tell you exactly what happened
because I know what happened I know for
a fact there's a small community of
people who do this I know exactly what
happened this is the story about Alec
Baldwin this is what this armor armorer
said to me I hope I don't get anyone
fired here he said what happens is on
these movie sets a lot of sitting around
and waiting people get bored and the
armors like to actually mess around with
guns and do target practice and so they
put live rounds in the guns they are
real guns a lot of them and they they
have to look real and they have to act
real in some scenes they have to
actually do shoot they have to shoot
they have to physically shoot and so the
the armors like you know to make to to
make the time pass they actually do
target practice with these things and he
says this armor says they left around
live around in there um
and they handed it to Alec Baldwin and
Alec Baldwin pulled the trigger and
killed it I'm not saying in any universe
that Alec Baldwin should not be held
accountable for this but he said that
there was a projectile left in the gun
and that that projectile was just lazy
like someone being lazy someone being
bored on the set put a live round except
he uh apparently he had pulled the gun
out and pulled the hammer back several
times meaning this revolver the the live
round was in the last in rotation which
means because the the shot required the
dummy rounds to be in it so it looked
like it was loaded someone put in a
bunch of rounds maybe they opened it up
saw one and then filled it with the
dummy ones not realizing I'd imagine
they'd look different maybe they didn't
maybe they all look the same maybe
that's possible but I just look at that
and I'm like we have to make assumptions
about how it could have happened as
opposed to The Simple Solution which
which is Alec Baldwin
put a bullet in it yes yeah don't be
afraid of the gun I don't want this
story this Alec Baldwin sort of freak
people out about guns he did a horrible
um just like a a very irresponsible
thing and it's not the gun's fault if
you check the weapon it functions as
intended Alec Baldwin man did he put a
sour taste in people's mouths for
weapons and I just not in today's
culture we need more responsibility with
weapons less fear about weapons more
self-control my whole point on the whole
Alec Baldwin thinks it's come up
bracelet because now he might be charged
it's just they're like calculate how
many data points each story requires
let's say it was the armorers were doing
shooting practice and then they made a
mistake you have a whole bunch of
different points in this story they have
to line up to make this possible you
also have Alec Baldwin fighting with
crew and then shooting a woman and I'm
like the least amount of assumptions is
Alec Baldwin fights with crew member
later shoots kills crew member as
opposed to Alec Baldwin fights with crew
member doesn't think twice about it go
has private meeting with her doesn't
think twice about it someone else takes
gone doing target practice then someone
else goes to load gun and accidentally
puts live bullet only in the last
Chambers you know position then puts the
dummy rounds in the rest then gives it
Alec Baldwin who with 40 Years of
weapons experience doesn't check and
then points a moment he was fighting
with pulls up that hammer back several
times and then finally kills her and I'm
just like there's just way too much
there so you're saying there's malice
here you think that Alec Baldwin
intended to kill her so a bunch of the
reporting was that he had been fighting
with crew members and crew were starting
to walk off and then there was an
interview he gave where he was calling
her like Intense or something like not
not saying anything very favorable or he
had a meeting with her and apparently
that he tried he tried saying it first
he wasn't friends with him later he was
friends with her or something like that
it's been a while since we covered all
the details of the story but I'm just
saying that to have a story that
involves the armorer some crew doing
shooting practice the armor like Alec
Baldwin And The Angry crew
you have a very circuitous plot about
framing Alec Baldwin or a potential
accident which requires you know getting
10 numbers correct in a row versus Alec
Baldwin did not have kind words with her
the crew was starting to walk off the
state the set and then Alec Baldwin shot
and killed her so it's like the big the
big point for me on this one is that
Alec Baldwin has training on firearms
and to be handed a weapon and back you
got it bang whoops it's like in what he
he made the argument that he's not
allowed to check firearms and hand it to
him because it's not a bad point it's a
good defense he said if I'm handing a
gun and then I open it up and start
fidgeting with it they're going to take
it from me what did you just do to it we
checked it to make sure it was safe so
when they give you the gun you just
point and shoot at people and my
argument there is no way no you check it
with the armor right two of you together
and then and and you're with them and
they open it up and they show you the
rounds and they say these are the rounds
we got them from this box we're putting
them in and then they should probably
cycle them if they're dummies and then
open it again close it hand it to the
actor to do the scene but Alec Baldwin
is hubris with four years experience
felt Untouchable you probably haven't
had a drinking the night before maybe
not but brain fog didn't care was pissed
off at Helena because he didn't like her
anyway just totally lazy thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there